we're losing light and our brain let's
do this quick no Timon is Garcelle baby
no no you know your life is different
now temper favorites video I haven't
done one of these in you know since the
last time I did one of these so here are
some things that I am liking slightly
more than other things at the current
moment in time let's just jump right in
first yeah okay I'll see ya I'll see ya
see if you watch any of you tea gurus
here on YouTube I'm sure you already
know what this is this tarts shaped ape
contour concealer it is so good I got
this for free
shout out to Val Harvey aka Mohawk
mohawk on instagram you should follow
her she basically does my makeup for
like everything for our show this might
get for any event I go to and she got
sent a bunch of Tarte products and gave
me this for free and it's awesome you
like full coverage concealer on your
under eyes like I do I want like a Harry
Potter invisibility cloak on these bad
boys under here I got to get these bags
registered in the witness protection
program so I can disguise them that's
how bad they are sometimes so this does
an amazing job it's full coverage for me
but still feels kind of light doesn't
get like cakey look wow wow look wow I'm
in this cute next another makeup item
can you see it I'll say yeah see I'm
pretty sure also from Val I'm pretty
sure she used this on me for some event
and then gave me this to take with me to
do my own touch-ups and I just sorry Val
never gave it back it's a NARS lip gloss
I'm wearing it right now Wow it's called
strip tease it mean it sort of looks
like the colour or vagina sponsor me
makeup companies look it's way Pinker
than it looks in this little thing and
it's not like shimmery which I thought
it was gonna be I just found at the
bottom eye makeup bag the other day and
try to loved it wearing it just light
smooth not sticky like a good strip
tease you don't want to be sticky
sponsor me NARS cute maxi hang-up say
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say these are
sunglasses that I got from Nasty Gal
calm and the next couple things I'm
showing you are also from Nasty Gal calm
these are just sunglasses that I got on
their website I did a full like been on
their website because they had like 80%
off of like most of their website true
story go check them out 80% off I don't
know if they're just like priced way too
high to begin
but you got me I think these ended up
being like $8 oh look how cool I love
sunglasses I have too many pairs but you
don't have a pair that doesn't fully
have the frame these sunglasses they're
a lot like me incomplete but trying hard
to look cool deal with that yeah riding
that nasty gal where next thing you'll
see you can see it
these are booties also from Nasty Gal
calm look at them Oh someone call Chris
Harrison because we lost studs happening
in this room right now okay yeah I know
that was symbolic they're covered in
dust because they wore them on the beach
today because I don't wear appropriate
things for appropriate location I think
these were 60% off on the website so I
think they're ended up being like 40
bucks and they got the zipper sides
which I love so much because there's so
much easier to take on and off they're
super comfortable a lot of times boots
rub the ankle part of you it give you
like a little painful ankle bracelet and
these don't so far we're them all day
today and they're kind of trendy but
they weren't that expensive so like I
look like I should be in the dorkiest
motorcycle gang of all time next yeah
yeah yeah see yeah see yeah this is a
dress that I bought off of nasty guy
come here let me show you the full thing
oh oh wow I look like 1/8 Isola
wiglesworth - I'm doing cosplay of that
parachute that they would have you play
with in gym class when your gym teacher
ran out of other ideas for you guys to
do either way it's super comfortable and
again was like 20 or 30 bucks off of
nasty guys website I love a boxy
shapeless piece of clothing that makes
people wonder if it's a dress where you
forgot to wear your pants it's a
conversation starter everywhere I go
cute next now we get into literature say
yeah yeah say yeah yeah say it this is a
book that has been recently published by
my good friend Franchesca Ramsey she's
been on TV on YouTube she's a wonderful
person and she just wrote I think this
is her first book Francesca correct me
if I'm wrong it's called well that
escalated quickly memoirs and mistakes
of an accidental activist I love
Francesca I've known her since I was
doing Daily Grace for years and years
and years and she's an absolutely
wonderful person and really hello
it has a lot of wonderful wonderful
stories just people that have been
quoted on the back of this book you so
Ray John Green Janet mock Ilana Glazer
Van Jones Jake Tapper like get it girl
she's been insanely supportive of all
the things that I do and I really want
to spread the love back at you I'm
really proud of you Francesca make sure
that you go check out I'll put links
down below where you can buy her book
see her on tour and just support this
overall wonderful human being that's
trying to do a lot to change the world
get a girl this is another book it's a
day in the life of Marlon Bund oh this
is I love this you probably know about
this but if you don't marvin bundo is
the name of Mike Pence's and the Vice
President of the United States is funny
that he and his family have Mike Penn
ISM been outspoken Lee against gay
marriage and just being gay in general
so John Oliver decided to write a
children's book actually it's written by
Marlon bunda with Jill Twist and it's
illustrated by eg Keller
they wrote a children's book about
Marlon bundle the bunny of Mike Pence
being gay and marrying his sweet sweet
handsome bunny love and it is such an
amazing book when this first came out I
was a little drunk shocked and I went on
Amazon I bought like six or seven copies
of it and it was backordered because
everyone went nuts to buy this and so
they finally got to my house a couple
weeks ago and I just read it and it's so
absolutely wonderful it's just like the
perfect silliest
wonderfullest creativeness Oh miss
funnest way to basically just
artistically slap someone in the face
that is pretty close minded while doing
it in an entertaining fashion and
creating a book that has a wonderful
message for both kids and adults alike
so how they recommend next can you see
it can you see it can you see it you
can't see it you can see it hi what are
you doing you took too many jello shots
too quickly at the party huh Christine
come on we're playing flip Cup there we
go my dear dear friend Harley Morenstein
sauce boss Epic Meal Time he invited me
on an episode of famous food truck where
I had to make hella big chicken and
waffles we got fried chicken waffles
grace
Helbig let's see how it pans out what's
the best thing that you've ever made
this fried chicken waffle combo me it
doesn't count because I'm making it no
get in there what something bad might
happen if I do this it's almost as if
you're not a chef you're a hell of big
chicken and waffles
let's make 50 of them boys and girls hey
you guys think about this
[Applause]
it was really fun
I love Harley I love being able to [ __ ]
on him whenever I get a chance in front
of a camera I'll link it all down below
but you can follow genius kitchen for
all the specifics on it it's a really
fun series and had a really great time
making it the results were edible people
ate it so alright that's it for my
favorites video for this month ish time
ish hope you guys enjoyed this if you
did give this video a thumbs up and
subscribe to this YouTube channel if you
haven't already hit that fel
notification because my upload schedule
is like my clothing choices questionable
and unpredictable other than that I
don't know when I wear them they make me
feel like I'm the kind of person that
thinks about possibly trying to maybe go
to stagecoach at some point if I got
free tickets randomly from someone else
without actually asking anyone putting
out into the universe thoughts or things
the secret cute